boy that's one of those questions you
almost have to ask somebody else one
thing I guess I learned a couple of good
lessons from my dad one was when you're
creating something that what you want
when you're working with a team of other
artists is you want everybody to work
with some creative freedom so that you
really get the best out of everybody and
he used to say people would say to him
when you finish a movie well did it come
out as good as you thought it was going
to or is is that it did you to come out
the way you intended it to come out and
my dad's answer will be usually
something to the effect of a it came out
better than he imagined but also he said
no it'll be impossible for me to imagine
the way it will come out he said yes I i
storyboarded it I had a plan but then I
work with an army of great artists and I
want all of them to create inside that
creation so as a director as a leader
and myself as a director and a leader I
kind of try to make sure that we hold
onto the vision and kind of corral it
but by the time you finish whatever the
project is a TV show a series a movie a
stage show it should be a product of
what all those people can do and
therefore it can never be what you
imagined it would be in the beginning
and it should be something that only
that group of people could have made
with everybody invested so in that sense
he and I I try to emulate his approach
of really get the most out of people by
allowing them to experiment and
certainly allowing people to make
mistakes I think in a creative effort in
any creative effort you need two people
need to be able to be taking risks and
and if it turns out to be a mistake if
it turns out not to have been the right
choice that should be applauded you know
by everybody and it will come up with
another plan but if everybody's trying
to stay safe then you never really
create something new and different and
surprising and so I try to operate like
him in that sense my dad was a very very
gentle soul um I'm probably not quite as
gentle maybe assess him but I certainly
try to respect people and create an
environment where people can flourish